bonsoir elle riait de bon coeur et ça va
nous faire rire
elle aimait la scène nous l'aimions sur
scène jacqueline maillan nous a quittés
elle avait 69 ans oui la rêverie
recettes de stars je suis là oui si j'ai
une spéciale il se fait lady clean air
est absolument j'ai une recette
personnelle - choucroute
vous allez beaucoup d'entre vous le
serez vous assez vite ou bien alors à
fatma chocolat je trouve pas plus légère
plus ils geste
je n'ai pas de charcuterie je mets du
filet si vous voulez norme ce texte est
bien aussi là confiait sa pelouse
alors écoutez mondiale et celle là ma
trouvaille qui nous lui rendre hommage à
la fin de ce journal en l'écoutant
encore plus longuement une première
étape vers l'europe sans frontières
franchi ce matin à l'assemblée nationale
les députés ont approuvé à une large
majorité le projet de révision de la
constitution un résultat inespéré pour
françois mitterrand et pierre bérégovoy
quelques semaines à peine après la
défaite des élections régionales les
socialistes ont réussi à constituer avec
l'udf une majorité d'idées sur l'europe
comme disait edgar faure du coup
l'opposition a affiché ces divergences
le rpr s'est en effet partagé entre un
vote hostile au projet à l'image de
philippe séguin et l'abstention à
l'image de jacques chirac et d'edouard
balladur
notre invité bonsoir monsieur balladur
avant de vous écouter
récit d'une nuit blanche à l'assemblée
nationale par jean baptiste près dany
jacques le deuil et christophe airaud
pour maîtrise l'assemblée a veillé tard
pour mettre la constitution alors de
l'europe
elle a vidé ses couloirs et battu des
records d'affluence
un hémicycle garni toutes les nuits pour
un débat sérieux de persévérance 25
heures de ces en non-stop 94
d'amendements examinés plus les
explications du premier ministre hier
soir ce matin chacun une dernière fois à
rassembler ses forces
résultat 3 198 voix pour la révision
constitutionnelle 77 compte unis dans
les applaudissements les socialistes
l'udf et laisse entrer au rpr après le
flottement l'abstention 31 anti
maastricht ont pourtant refusé de
s'aligner et ont suivi philippe séguin
au bout de la nuit
les explications je crois que c'est pour
leur
pour le groupe du rassemblement
aujourd'hui et par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé dans les quelques jours
derniers à mon avis un ressaisissement
il ya un rapport dont chacun sait
majoritairement hostiles à la réforme de
ce channel
président du rpr sous les termes des
réseaux internes au rpr
que ce soit un vote d'abstention du prix
de nous bush
nous sommes opposés ont des repères
opposition divisée
l'udf minimi l'opposition a eu le
courage et bien d'affirmer ses
convictions de faire de faire apparaître
ces différences et atteinte à ce moment
là d'avoir des ppte démontré qu'elle
était devenue adulte
après l'assemblée le sénat deuxième
étape pour l'humour rpr udf peut-être
deuxième obstacle
monsieur balladur vous même vous êtes
abstenu oui tout à fait et vous aviez
prenez l'abstention comme une sorte de
compromis l'abstention du rpr et celle
de l'idf
on n'avait pas été suivi ce que vous
l'enjeu a été suivie joue demande pardon
90 députés rpr en voter sur pour
l'abstention sur un peu plus de 120 fois
les gens l'idée à midi à l'udf en effet
il me semble il me semblait que la
formule de l'abstention était celle qui
nous permettait de nous retrouver pour
faire le point si je puis dire
je vous rappelle que la procédure à
plusieurs étapes c'est la première étape
devant l'assemblée ensuite on doit aller
devant le sénat et il me semblait que
l'abstention sur une affaire de ce genre
pourrait être une sorte d'avertissement
donné au gouvernement parce que nous
considérions que le texte tel qu'il est
avec les amendements qu'au départ le
gouvernement se disait décidé à accepter
ça n'était pas assez je rappelle en
passant que nombre d'entre nous sont
dont moi-même sont favorables à la
ratification des accords de maastricht
ce que je confirme une nouvelle fois
vous êtes européen tout à fait sous
réserve que certaines garanties nous
soit donnée c'est ce qu'une opinion peut
ne pas comprendre ça paraît
contradictoire ne pas volts et leur
projet de révision de la constitution
est approuvée maastricht mais les deux
opérations n'ont pas lieu à la même date
monsieur pas la marne va on commence par
nous dire on a ratifié maestris mais il
faut d'abord modifier la constitution
bien j'observe qu'on aurait peut-être pu
s'en apercevoir un peu plus tôt mme un
peu importe on l'a pas fait et nous
disons ce traité pour nous va dans la
bonne direction
nous sommes nombreux à le dire pas
touche mais nombreux mais il faut
prendre un certain nombre de précautions
c'est ce que j'ai dit dès le premier
3 or il nous a semblé que c'était
précaution n'était pas suffisante en
revanche nos partenaires de l'udf
l e pardon les trouvais suffisante alors
c'est pourquoi j'avais proposé que nous
nous abstenons dans une première phase
avant que le sénat ne reprenne des
choses et que nous jugions
définitivement à l'arrêt monsieur le
ministre est ce que les sentiments que
l'élève a lâché non non non pas du tout
aisée il faut savoir ce qu'on veut
soit dans l'existence nous avons fait le
choix de la liberté de la démocratie et
notamment au groupe rpr et dans
l'opposition de façon générale il n'ya
pas de discipline de vote chacun vote
selon sa conscience à la donne une
mauvaise image
ça ne donne pas une image pour l'instant
de très grande cohésion c'est vrai mais
nous allons voir ce qui va se passer au
sénat et vous verrez ensuite qu'au
retour à l'assemblée nationale les
choses se passeront de celles afférentes
partie des députés repères vous ont
suivi se sont abstenus notre parti a
voté contre
est ce que leur père est menacée
d'éclatement sur un sujet aussi
important certainement pas certainement
pas d'ailleurs sur des sujets tels que
l'europe une certaine diversité je
dirais quasi de tradition rpr et nous
pratiquons pas de monolithisme ceux
d'entre nous qui sont contre l'europe
ont pu s'exprimer très longuement à 1
reste ce qui s'est passé pour les
socialistes mais ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que une fois cette affaire réglée
elle le sera d'une façon de l'autre je
souhaite qu'au sénat le gouvernement
fasse des concessions complémentaires
car il ya encore des concessions qu'il
doit faire on parle des vrais en page d
autres vrais problèmes de notre pays
aujourd'hui même où hier on a publié sur
la sécurité sur la délinquance des
statistiques très inquiétante
il y a un plan d'urgence contre le
chômage dont j'ai des raisons de penser
qu'il ne donnera pas beaucoup de
résultats
la sécurité le chômage l'essec l'échec
scolaire les déficits les retraites
voilà les vrais problèmes qui
intéressent les français et je
souhaiterais que le gouvernement
n'utilise pas ce débat qui certes est un
débat important comme une sorte de
rideau de fumée comme un moyen de créer
des difficultés aux autres pour se
dispenser de résoudre les difficultés du
pays évoquons la perception que peut
avoir l'électorat de l'opposition votre
élection monsieur balladur de ce qui
s'est passé
hier 93 élections législatives souvent
on vous présente comme le futur premier
ministre de cohabitation
il y aura si vous gagnez les élections
évidemment il y aura une autre
cohabitation udf rpr
comment gouverner ensemble quand on
n'est pas d'accord sur l'europe ben nous
c'est que nous sommes d'accord sur
l'europe
nous sommes d'accord sur l'europe et
dans notre vision sur ce qu'il faut
faire dans les années qui viennent
certes si vous nous demandez ce que
devra être l'europe en l'an 2000 5 ou en
en 2010 les uns vous diront ça devrait
être une fédération et les autres vous
diront non il faut que chaque don nous
mêmes chaque nation doit conserver entre
les mains les instruments essentiels de
la maîtrise de son destin
bon mais nous n'en sommes pas là pour
l'instant il s'agira en 1993 si les
français nous font confiance nous devons
faire des efforts pour cela car nous
avons gagné les élections régionales et
cantonales
mais il nous reste à gagner les
élections législatives et ce n'est pas
joué d'avancé
il faut que nous soyons très vigilants
eh bien je les français devront nous
faire confiance s'ils le font sur la
base d'un programme clair et précis
est-ce que l'opposition n'a pas fait
hier un superbe cadeau politique à
françois mitterrand imaginons un
référendum sur l'europe et une
opposition divisée qui a écouté nous ne
sommes pas là pour l'instant il faut
modifier la constitution
nous allons voir comment les choses vont
se passer au sénat et au retour les
conclusions que nous en tirerons à
l'assemblée je suis de ceux qui
regarderont la chose dans un esprit je
dirais totalement honnête pour ma part
je le répète encore une fois la
ratification du traité de maastricht ne
me pose pas de problème particulier sous
réserve qu'un certain nombre de
précautions soient prises
quelques-unes ont été prises d'autres ce
n'est pas encore suffisant
quoi qu'il en soit nous avons fait le
choix de l'union de l'union de
l'opposition
la tentative que nous avons fait
d'essayer de rassembler tout le monde
sur cette formule de l'abstention était
justifiée par notre désir de l'union
elle n'a pas réussi autant vous le dire
c'est la vérité vous ne diriez le sujet
disait le contraire vous auriez raison
elle n'a pas réussi mais pour autant
notre choix fondamental d'offrir une
alternative aux français pour une autre
politique pour notre pays et dans une
union avec nos partenaires n'est pas
remise en cause
le pape a en tout cas pas par ce qui
s'est passé au jour en un mot vous ne
croyez pas un possible renversement
d'alliance par exemple l'alliance
d'idées entre certains centristes et les
socialistes absolument pas je suis
convaincu que ma bien que nous ayons
certaines divergences entre nous c'est
vrai nous sommes unis sur l'essentiel
merci monsieur balladur le préfet de
haute-corse henri durand a été placé en
position hors cadre une décision prise
par le ministre de l'intérieur et
approuvé par le conseil des ministres à
la suite je cite le porte parole du
gouvernement à la suite des
insuffisances apparu dans le
fonctionnement de l'administration en
corse façon pudique de mettre l'accent
sur la responsabilité du préfet dans le
drame de furiani
en clair c'est une sanction et ce n'est
pas la seule trois nouvelles
inculpations ont été prononcées
aujourd'hui à bastia ce qui porte à six
le nombre de personnes mises en cause
reportage sur place de maxime mellerio
jean-marie vois mon a été transféré hier
soir dans une prison du continent par
mesure de sécurité
c'est l'ingénieur de sub tribune chargée
du montage de la structure
une seconde personne a été écrouée dans
le même laps de temps
il s'agit de bernard roos directeur de
la socotec accusé de ne pas avoir
effectué les contrôles de sécurité
inhérents à cette manifestation
le juge rousseau convoque depuis hier
les différents acteurs de cette tragédie
à commencer par jean françois filippi
entendu depuis hier 11 heures
hospitalisé cette nuit puis reconduit ce
matin dans les locaux de la gendarmerie
de bastia
il serait déféré au parquet dans les
prochaines heures
autres personnes entendues et inculpé
michel lorentz vice président étienne
galets hats secrétaire général de la
ligue force noël bartoli de la ligue
corse de football
également chef d'inculpation retenu
coups et blessures involontaires faux et
usage de faux
ces personnes ont été remises en liberté
d'autres interpellations devraient
suivre toutes les sanctions qui tombent
en cascade sont fondés sur le contenu du
rapport établi par la commission
denquête un rapport accablant pour la
société sud tribune la fédération
française de football et la commission
départementale de sécurité hervé dit nos
constructions métalliques en raison de
la configuration adoptée par l'ingénieur
dessus tribune ne pouvait
que s'effondrer et transformer le public
accueilli en victime responsable numéro
un de la catastrophe aux yeux de la
commission denquête la société sud
tribune à l'évidence les gradins
installés à furiani ne pouvait supporter
la charge de spectateurs qu'il devait
accueillir
par ailleurs les experts ont relevé
plusieurs erreurs de montage pour livrer
l'édifice dans les délais ce une tribune
à bâcler le travail
en revanche la socotec dont le
responsable local a été inculpé est elle
relativement épargnée la commission
constate simplement que sa mission de
contrôle technique était floue et
uniquement définie par un contrat oral
mais ce que souligne surtout le rapport
c'est qu'à aucun moment les autorités
sportives et administratives ne se sont
souciés des modalités de ce contrôle
la commission départementale de sécurité
filmée ici
la veille du drame et désigner du doigt
après avoir rendu un premier avis
défavorable c'est elle qui finalement a
donné son feu vert trois heures à peine
avant le début de la rencontre
une décision justifiée selon certains
par les particularismes locaux
nous sommes en corse nous il s'agit d'un
match que tout le monde veut il s'agit
d'une fête que tout le monde veut
préparer
il s'agit d'une expression globale à
laquelle tout le monde veut participer
je me dis moi je sais pas qui c'est
quelqu'un capable résister à ce type de
pression président de la commission de
sécurité le préfet est directement mise
en cause on lui reproche d'avoir négligé
les problèmes de faisabilité du projet
le club de bastia et la ligue de
football ont également leur part de
responsabilité dans le drame
ils ont fait construire la tribune sans
autorisation et ne l'ont pas vérifié
après édification au passage la
commission d' enquête relève que le club
bastia détourné près de la moitié des
recettes du match et jean fournet-fayard
le président de la fédération française
de football a été aujourd'hui longuement
entendu par les gendarmes à paris avec
deux autres responsables de la
fédération le parlement à l'assaut d'un
monopole celui des dockers cgt mais des
parlementaires comme le gouvernement
auront du mal à convaincre cette
profession de la nécessité d'une réforme
des statuts agnès molinier quelques
responsables nationaux des dockers sont
venus écouter le débat plutôt dubitatif
sur un texte qui remettent en cause leur
statut établi en 47 intermittents avec
une rémunération garantie nationalement
pendant les périodes dit n'emploie ils
deviendraient des salariés mensualisés
et la gestion de leurs effectifs se
ferait port par port
pour le gouvernement cette réforme est
indispensable ne laissons pas dire que
la situation serait idyllique
il a appelé d'emplois dans les ports
malheureusement et on travaille un jour
sur deux
et là notre ambition c'est de faire en
sorte que la régularité du travail géré
par les entreprises permettent garantie
rémunérations et retraites amélioré par
exemple aussi bref que les entreprises
et les dockers redonne la compétitivité
de nos pauvres ont absolument besoin
seul parti communiste s'est déclaré
hostile au principe de cette réforme il
va présenter les amendements de la cgt
pour eux la mensualisation est un recul
inadmissible
la mensualisation c'est quoi ces cons
casserait ces garanties et des dockers
seraient employés dans des entreprises
comme dans toute autre entreprise l on
prendrait peut les autres seraient
licenciés on prévoit un plan social
un licenciement sur deux aujourd'hui les
dockers sont très mobilisés comme ici
ceux de calais et boulogne depuis
octobre il multiplie les arrêts de
travail et sont en grève cette semaine
une fois la réforme votée il pourrait
décider de tout faire pour empêcher
qu'elles soient impliqués des quartiers
plus sûrs dans des villes humaine c'est
le pari de bérets le premier ministre
pierre bérégovoy a présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres une série de
mesures destinées à transformer les
conditions de vie dans certains
quartiers où la ségrégation et la misère
s'accroissent à vue d'oeil
mais aussi et surtout à améliorer la
sécurité des citadins les policiers dans
les rues seront plus nombreux visible
caroline si ns - deux policiers derrière
les bureaux plus sur le terrain pour
lutter contre l'insécurité 3200
policiers seront affectés en renfort
dans les rues
c'est la première décision du plan
sécurité mille policiers auxiliaires des
appelés du contingent seront utilisés
mille emplois administratifs créé 27
départements très urbanisé en
bénéficieront en priorité
deuxième décision travailler sur des
objectifs prioritaires parmi ceux ci la
lutte contre la drogue et contre les
bandes de délinquants des bureaux de
police s'installeront dans les quartiers
sensibles
la sécurité dans les lieux publics tels
les écoles ou les transports sera
renforcée les personnes âgées pourront
bénéficier d'une protection il faut
prévenir c'est d'ailleurs en poche
empêcher que se crée un climat
d'insécurité
ensuite il faut dissuader c'est à dire
faire en sorte que les délinquants
potentiels ne puisse pas agir réduire et
enfin si la prévention et de dissuasion
n'ont pas suffi à ce moment là il faut
réprimer toutes ces mesures demanderont
plus de travail aux policiers il est
donc prévu d'améliorer leurs conditions
de vie au niveau des salaires et du
logement
le plan sécurité doit aider à retrouver
des quartiers sur dans les grandes
villes il est applicable immédiatement
quels seront les effets de ce plan
d'action gouvernemental qui veut en fait
concilier répression et prévention en
quête de nathalie darrigrand et philippe
dina chanteloup les vignes près de paris
une banlieue comme une autre c'est à
dire difficile chanteloup-les-vignes
site elano et 45 % de la population a
moins de 20 ans le taux de chômage frôle
les 15 % en 90 des échauffourées entre
jeunes ont fait parler de la ville de la
cité
depuis certains magasins restent fermés
le supermarché le bureau de tabac
le journal la sécurité c'est un problème
quotidien ici dix mille habitants
seulement dix policiers et quatre
auxiliaires pour les encadrer dans ces
conditions la noce du renforcement des
effectifs de la police ne peut être que
bien perçu je dirais que ces mesures
seront d'autant plus efficaces si
derrière sur le plan judiciaire et sur
le plan éducatif des moyens sont donnés
pour permettre que derrière le travail
de la police
il ya une action suivie au niveau
notamment les jeunes qui posent problème
par leur comportement avec eux à partir
de là je pourrais vous dire si c'est
efficace à chanteloup s'il a fait plus
de dix ans que les responsables se bat
pour que la répression s'accompagne de
la prévention pas moins de 80
associations animent le quartier et
comme toujours côté jeunes on affirme
que le dialogue est plus important que
l'autorité je pense qu'aux états unis on
à renforcer énormément pour certains
répression malheureusement ça n'a pas
aidé les choses que lé feu et flammes se
relance en chine est bon ici nous ne
sommes pas à l'abri mais quand même il
ya des solutions il y avait des actions
qui peuvent être mises en place et qui
sont certaines pour jamais d'emplois
dans certains quartiers qui feront
peut-être que ça ne se passera pas la
même chose et comme pour l'illustrer
toute la cité s'accorde pour dire que
les seules l'uniforme véritablement
intégré ici sont ceux des deux seuls
policiers municipaux eux qui n'ont pas
de pouvoir répressif celui uniquement
d'écouter un accident s'est produit ce
matin boye en loire atlantique deux cars
transportant des enfants ont été percuté
par un poids lourd qui roulait sans
doute trop vite
douze personnes dont huit enfants ont
été blessés et hospitalisés
ils ne sont pas en danger trente cinq
autres passagers ont été soignés sur
place
la lituanie indépendante soit en visite
officielle son premier chef d'état
occidental en l'occurrence le nôtre
françois mitterrand est arrivé cet après
midi à vilnius
première étape d'une visite de trois
jours dans la république balte reportage
de pascal verneau camichel l'hommage de
françois mitterrand aux victimes de la
répression sanglante de vilnius en
janvier 91
dix-sept civils tombés sous les balles
des pères et noir soviétique toute la
portée symbolique d'une visite en
quelques images
la france veut t'aider la lituanie a
consolidé son indépendance et à
s'insérer dans les grands flux
économiques mondiaux la lituanie
ballotté par les vents de l'histoire en
pleine interrogation
faut-il introduire une monnaie nationale
et quitter la zone rouble
alors qu'à l'ouest on va vers la monnaie
unique faut-il conserver un président ce
sera l'objet du prochain référendum
enfin qui doit être citoyens lituaniens
traduisez comment préserver les droits
des minorités polonaise au russophone
des questions qui sous-tendent
l'entretien entre françois mitterrand et
vito tu as landsberg is les deux hommes
se connaissent bien
connivence de l'histoire et de la
culture mais il leur faudra aussi par
l'économie l'attentisme des industriels
français n'est plus de mise dit-on à
vilnius
car il existe désormais un accord
réciproque de protection des
investissements
enfin et cela fait partie des craintes d
homme politique lituanien le départ des
ex soldats soviétiques n'est toujours
pas effectif
il y a quelques semaines à paris le
président landsberg affirmé que cette
énorme armée pouvait encore constituer
un danger pour l'europe et bien sur ce
sujet paris attend désormais un geste de
la part de boris eltsine peut-être un
début de calendrier de retrait amériques
de italie 1 la coupe de l'america est de
nouveau dominé par les autochtones qui
ont battu hier il mauro di venezia cette
coupe vous l'avez suivi largement sur la
3 grâce à thalassa et vous vivrez
d'autres événements sportifs sur l'a3
comme sur l'a2 dans les semaines les
mois les années prochaines
hervé bourges le pdg des deux chaînes
considère le sport comme une priorité
stratégique pour le groupe public et a
annoncé ce matin au cours d'une
conférence de presse que retour du
football
ce sera le gage dès ce soir à antenne 2
à 20h30
et ce sera le cas sur nos deux chaînes
en juin prochain pour le championnat
d'europe de football
découvrons ensemble les rendez-vous
quand n 2 et fr3 vous propose dès le 10
juin suède prend donc le premier match
de ce championnat d'europe sur antenne 2
et d'autres matches comme le dimanche 14
à 20 heures sur fr3 suède yougoslavie ou
le jeudi
18 juin pays bas allemagne un superbe
match j'imagine à 20h15 sur notre chaîne
on aura évidemment l'occasion d'en
reparler avant le mois de juin
vous le savez si vous nous fait l'amitié
d'être avec nous depuis le début de ce
journal jacqueline maillan nous a
quittés elle avait 69 ans elle était
très présente sur scène très discrète
dans la vie saluons la discrètement en
l'écoutant simplement du cabaret
l'amiral où elle fit ses débuts jusqu'à
la scène des grands théâtre de boulevard
jacqueline maillan a toujours servi le
rire la vie
moelleux diagne et personnels dont le
rappel c'est dans je crois papy fait de
la résistance où elle je crois elle
avait un le rôle de la femme du du
papier en question quoi et c'est un
personnage de grande bourgeoise avec il
a parlé un petit peu étonnant très snob
et entend très vulgaire il est clair
qu'on place ça je ne discute pas alors
c'est très simple je le vends les
allemands et leur expliquer que nous
pouvons pas recevoir sujet parce que
voilà est-ce que vous avez bien lu notre
question c'est marrant parce que
bon sinon j'aurais pas pu vous donner
rendez-vous si j'avais pas le téléphone
se marre c'est marrant les grands
timides
et nous lui rendre hommage sur fr3
dimanche à 20h45 avec la comédie de
pierre mondy appelez-moi matile fin de
ce 19 à marcq hautement 22h20 florence
klein 20 heures bonne soirée à demain
19h bonsoir
nous tous